If we start acting now on climate change,...
...then we can still be in for a bright future.
But it is important that each and everyone of us continues to fight against climate change...
...and what it does to our world.
When I travel, I see many original, innovative,...
...smart climate solutions in every member state.
They are put in place by innovative people,...
...who just happen to have a great idea which saves greenhouse gas emissions...
...and at the same time money.
To encourage all the innovators amongst you, I've just launched a Europe-wide contest...
...as part of "A World You Like with the Climate You Like" campaign.
I'm looking for the best solutions to reduce greenhouse gas emissions, big or small.
Whether you are an individual or an organization.
Because the engagement of every single one of us counts.
Because the actions of every single one of us will make the difference.
For a start, you can turn off your lights.
This certainly is not the solution, but it is a reminder...
...and a good opportunity for you to stop and think.
So, I would like to invite you to participate in Earth Hour...
...for one hour on Saturday, the 23rd of March,...
...starting at 8:30 in the evening.
You will have time to think about what you can do...
...to secure a world you like with the climate you like.